Welcome everybody to another zoom call
Just a reminder apologize for my road the end of the day. I'm kind of
My lost my voice
Anybody knows me is very sad happy about that, but um
Feel free to chat in questions. We have a bunch of questions that came in but feel free to chat in some questions for my dear
The announcements are on the home members home page
The first question
I added this little box because
They asked about a about dms. Oh, so what are your thoughts and experience with protocol treatments using dms. Oh
and
This was an article that they linked to with dms. Oh in cancer
So what's the benefit of dms. Oh with cancer?
So dms. Oh first of all is a great
Anti-inflammatory topical anti-inflammatory. That's how it was first
really used
medicinally
as a anti-inflammatory so you put some liquid dms. Oh, it's like water
die methyl sulfoxide and
You put it on your knee that's injured and it can decrease the inflammation of your knee
quite quickly
The positive of dms. Oh is that it is absorbed like instantaneously through the skin and
It is it goes right into the cell membranes
And it can it can go deep the negative is because it absorbs so quickly
It pulls
What you may have on the skin
So let's say if you have some lotion with parabens and other toxins on your skin and you put dms. Oh over it
You're going to be pulling that stuff right into your tissues
Which that could be a bad thing
So if you have toxins on your skin and you use dms. Oh, you're pulling toxins right in it's it is
It just pulls with it whatever's next to it
So that is a negative of dms. Oh, it's something you have to be careful of so you want to wash your skin and
have clean skin
and
Make sure that it's not going to be a carrier and
Pulse it into the tissue. We've used dms. Oh for years and years. We have our own dms. Oh zig spray
That people have used topically over breast cancer over or prostate over
So that is something to use you could buy dms. Oh just on Amazon. It's very inexpensive
People use it to pull other things like though and zinc to it like we did to pull things through the tissue
You could have curk some a little bit of curk them in cream on your
your breast, let's say and you put dms. Oh over it
We've used dms. Oh as an ointment mixture with the curk him and cream. It'll pull the curk him and into the tissue
So there's pros to it
There's if you looked at this article
There's other articles that have shown that dms. Oh could actually stimulate a poptosis sick and block certain
Unca gene pathways it. There's other
cancer positive cancer things with dms. Oh
But with anything like this there's also a flip side. We've had people use dms. Oh on their breast cancer and they
Strongly felt that it made it much worse
So what's you just have to be careful with
Anything that you do and to test it. So dms. Oh is not a nutritional supplement
Even though you can buy it over the calder. It's thought to be generally safe
You could overuse it
dms. Oh also will give off a sulfur group
Because it's that's one of the things in it is sulfur
Now the danger of having excess sulfur that can push the glutathione pathway
So there is some downsides with using dms. Oh with that you could increase
Glutathione production and for cancer patients we've described in detail why that may not be a good thing
so
While people have used dms. Oh for cancer effectively for inflammation effectively
We've had just as many people that said that it made things worse
So you do have to be careful with everything you do. This is uh
Would be considered in my classification as a drug not as a nutritional supplement
Whereas if you did if you took a conatia or you took garlic
Yeah, I could have it down side if garlic and have a downside if you're taking a medical blood deterred
You could have too much blood that eat but
The there really isn't the downside with garlic and cancer
But there can be a downside with the MSO and cancer so
Just be careful with using different protocols
Um, you have to make sure you test things and go slowly with things
Next question can the rife be used with pregnancy?
Yes, we've always said that the rife is safe with pregnancy
Now understand if you google the rife with pregnancy you may begin another answer because a lot of things
We'll define a rife machine differently
If what a lot of people use a p-e-m-f and they call it rife
So
A p-e-m-f is a post-electromagnetic field therapy
The sheet that's electrical frequencies is our electrical frequencies. Okay with pregnancy
Generally no not over your uterus
So you have to be careful with electrical frequencies. Could you use the p-e-m-f on your feet?
Yes, could you use the p-e-m-f whole body at a very low dose
low-gouse? Yes
But you would use a high-gouse p-e-m-f over the abdominal cavity if you're pregnant
So but a lot of people will classify rife as
As electrical as an electrical therapy. So we're talking rife. We're talking about light frequencies with a
plasma field tesla tube
What you guys all know of as a rife machine well out there in the world
Lots of people call all sorts of things by different names
So the rife machine that you have is
Completely acceptable for use with pregnancy
What are your thoughts on sour shop?
So sour shop is another name for graviolla
So anybody that's taking our black sap blood root capsules is taking graviolla
a.k.a sour shop
so
Sour shop is fine to take it's it's another tensor killing
uh
nutrient just like
the
100 other cancer killing nutrients out there
um, but somebody actually asked me this in a
consult today when they asked about they had some liquid sour shop
Can they take that? Well, they're already taking black sap blood root. I put there
I don't think there's any harm in
Taking if you had the liquid sour shop to go ahead and take that as well
It's not taking that
Should I continue to do thermography?
So I don't know who was I asked this question, but
yes
If you are doing if you've done thermography for breast exam
I was assuming this person has done thermography for breast exams
in the past
Maybe got a positive fighting and then maybe went the medical route
He's going to biopsy blah blah blah now they're under care for cancer for breast cancer
Should you continue to do thermography? I think highly advisable to continue to do thermography because it can be a very
Simple not invasive screening tool moving forward
Now there may be some some
Artifacts let's go over from let's say the biopsy so you have this
The incision and blah blah blah and take that into account when you read the thermography
Um, but uh, yes continue to do thermography. It's a great screening tool
To screen progress as well. So answer yes
What is the benefit of doing a soda if I'm not really sweating
Well, it's not uncommon that people will start doing soda
and
Get frustrated because they're not sweating
Um, but just keep it up. I've never had a person
continue to do a soda and try to stay in there for 20
Plus minutes and have it they're not end up getting a breakthrough where they start sweating
um, I know there are people it has to do neurologically
um
with uh, your
With the sweat glands themselves
So if you keep up doing a soda and
You will end up getting a breakthrough and you will end up sweating the whole idea of doing a sauna is really too sweat
So this person must have heard me say that before and it's like well, what am I doing a sauna for?
I'll be there for 15 minutes and I'm not even sweating
Well, continue to do it. There's there are other benefits of the heat as well
But you really want to start sweating and you will end up getting a breakthrough and you will start sweating
It can take a long time for some people
To really have experience have that experience
The majority of people start sweating in about two minutes at a sauna
But um, that's not you just keep it up keep doing it on a regular basis
So you will so that won't be an issue
I started exploring other more of the atelier ramen functions
It was wondering if the scanner mode or scanner hits mode has valuable information. I should be tracking
No, not at all
So if you're not using the scanner apparatus that plugs into that
One black outlet on the front of the machine
It you're not scanning so you um
You're
You shouldn't be doing anything with the scanner the scanner hits
Scanner mode or anything like that. It's completely mute
So don't even think about that or worry about that
Sometimes the ball gets so hot. I will set it on the floor beside our bed
Is this okay to do? Is it still effective next to our bed?
Yes, it is
But remember the farther the bulb is away to
Your body the you are
Losing effectiveness
So if you're too hot, I always
Recommend that you just move the ball maybe a foot away from you
Um on your bed
Even if you're sleeping in a single bed you should still be able to
Be lying comfortable with the with the bulb a foot away from you in bed
If uh if you're putting it on the floor beside your bed
You're still getting some benefits. I will say that we've had some line patients that have had to put the bulb in the next room
And run it and go slowly in the kill program in order to get
To where they're not hurt seen enough where they can bring it into the room
However, it is um
You're when you're trying to kill cancer patients are not worried about herxia. You're concerned about the heat of the bulb
And it's discomfort because you're warm
But um
But you so you need it as close to you as possible
um
But that being said, yes, you can put it
12 to 18 inches away from you
um
and
Try to be as comfortable as possible
If it's three feet on the floor and it's going partially through the mattress to get to you
It's definitely going to have some filtration
And you're going to definitely lose some effectiveness
MCP your modified citrus pectin is referenced in your cancer book as an important supplement to take to help prevent the
Stasis
Or I've already had my lung cancer metastasized once
Would this be a good addition for my supplement protocol
Well modified citrus pectin would not be contraindicated for anybody
So um
Yes, you could add modified citrus pectin to your protocol
Now
Couple downsides with modified citrus pectin we have some people
Uh, that are taking it and are putting it right in their smoothie
Um with the other things that they have in their smoothie whatever it is
And blending it and drinking it that way
That seems to work well
If you're going to take modified citrus pectin the powder
And you're going to take it separate from a smoothie
The warning is it doesn't dissolve in water
really at all
And you're going to get frustrated it does dissolve instantly in a little orange juice
Well orange juice is a lot of sugar
Yeah, but if you just do three ounces orange juice
Put your modified citrus pectin it'll dissolve and make it thicker
But then you'll be able to gulp that down if you're not taking it with a smoothie
Um, it's best to put it in orange juice
I know some people have put it with some lemon juice
Uh, or some lemonade has to be like a citrus juice
In order for it to absorb well
If you read the literature literature that I've read written about
modified citrus pectin in a perfect scenario
You're taking it more on an empty stomach
Um, with some orange juice
But we also realize that
It's really hard to
Believe in a perfect scenario I talk to people all the time that are like
It's really hard for me to split my supplements up three times a day
Life gets in the way
So it's difficult to stay on a protocol where you're taking that on a
Relatively empty stomach and you've got so many other different pieces of your protocol
It's hard to stay motivated, especially if you're doing well
Um, to stick to something like that
So I've always told people just go ahead if it's easier to just put it in your smoothie
It's just going to be easier to do it
Still going to get 99% of the benefit of it
But is there anything wrong with somebody adding
Modified citrus pectin that I didn't tell them to add
No, everybody can add that there's no there's no downside to that
Should I update the supplements that you recommended after my cheek swab testing
To include the one in the protocols that you created for my cancer type on small cell lung cancer
Um
Where there are several protocols and many extra supplements
In the member site under protocols
No, don't do that
So I have those protocols in there just for people to look at
I've created all those protocols
But um, it's just for informational sake
And if you really want to look at and spray about like is there
What would be the next thing to add
Just like that other question about adding modified citrus pectin or adding this or adding that
You can look at those protocols. Does it mean that you should do them? No
Does it mean that you can? Yes, but you don't have to
So but if you look at that and you go I really I was thinking about this one and I
And let me then pray about it if you want to add one thing or something else then
Then by all means you're welcome to do so, but you're not obligated to do so so
Really you're not obligated to do anything
But you're the recommendations that you just follow when I gave you all your cheek swab test
My right indicates
Program duration can be changed by changing the duty cycle
or duty number
Is that okay? Are they until you're robbing? So
The until you're robbing and the true rife program use that same command called duty
so the duty of
number is
is um
On your until you're robbing has to do with the amount of time that the
Frequency is on a certain number so
That if you're gonna want to change the duration of a program the length of a program
You don't change the duty cycle
You change the command that's called
dwell
So dwell is the command on both the true rife and the until you're robbing
That tells you how long it's going to dwell on a given frequency
So let's say it says dwell 180
All right, let's do it this way. So let's say the program says dwell 180
Then underneath it has I don't know let's just put in some numbers here
five four six and two three four and ten thousand
four hundred fifty six so that it's got another line with
with some numbers and
Like this
And then it's got another line with some numbers
That means these are the frequencies
That are be dwelled on for 180 seconds
So there's certain commands in the rife program
That the program itself will ignore the letters
Duel and will ignore whatever comes after that on that same line
And it doesn't sense that as a frequency that is being run
That's being run or being asked to be in ronda
On the following lines if there's not a command dwell or duty or pulse or
Things like that those are certain commands that tell the machine to do certain things
And it's just a number and that's the frequency that is
running
Or will run in the program do not mess with these numbers
If you mess with these numbers you've literally changed your program
What your program is it consists of
duty cycles
dwells
pulse commands all sorts of different commands
And it could then it consists of the numbers which are the frequencies that are running
Duel is
How long it stays on a given frequency in numbers of seconds so this is 180 seconds dwelling 180 seconds
Everything below that line and tell the dwelle is switched again. So then if it says dwelle
90 then it has a bunch of other
Numbers after that
As long as you put a kaba between the numbers then that means that's the frequency of
2345 and the frequency of 4556
Or you have it on a separate line like I did with these
So that means you're continuing to run that so now the dwelle has changed
The dwelle has changed
To now it'll only run these two frequencies at 90 seconds each
So that's how those are those commands I recommend you don't mess with them at all
If you if you mess with the duty cycle you're going to screw up the program completely
Do not ever mess with the duty cycle because there are certain rules in writing programs that have to do with duties
So if you go into your program and you plan playing with the duty cycle you could wreck your machine
Um, so
It's just as simple as that with the true rife
um
With either machine you could just you could burn out you could you could load a machine
So you never mess with the duty cycles
Okay
You can but
You're your machine's gonna not work and you're gonna be probably me to have it fixed so
um
Don't ever mess with the duty cycles don't ever mess with the pulses don't ever mess you the only thing that I would say that you could safely
Play with is the dwelle um as you can't hurt anything by changing the dwelle
Well, let's take that back you could hurt you by changing the dwelle
Technically, I don't ever have anything dwelle on anything more than
Usually on an average frequency there's some frequencies that you could dwell up to 30 minutes
But on the average your dwelle lead
less than 300 seconds
so um
So but let's say you change this to 18,000 what all your programs are gonna be like 20 hours long probably
But um you by just by changing that it's not safe to be
dwelling on
These these frequencies that long so um
I
I realized that you want one to get technical and you want to do this yourself
No, I'm all poor if this is your machine you do whatever you want to do
But don't do things foolishly, okay, so um
Don't ever ever mess with the duty cycles and if you do mess with the dwells
Let's say let's say you wanted to turn uh
Let's say you were running a flu program, but it was only 90 minutes long
I want to make this nine hours
Will you don't just change the dwelle and let it dwelle on each frequency for 10 minutes
That's not good for you either so I just
Ask me to write a program that's gonna make a nine hour flu program. That's what you wanted
so
Uh, not giving you about telling you you can't do whichever you want to do with your machine, but
If you hurt yourself with your machine, that's on you though
If you hurt your machine, that's on you too, so um just be careful
Okay, question from the chat
I haven't doing my castor oil pack while I'm in the sauna for 45 minutes. It just occurred to me
That maybe I do not need to bother with covering my liver area
with the cloth cloth and plastic wrap
Do those provide any benefit over me
Just paint or just painting the castor oil on my skin
Over by liver and letting it soak in while I'm in the sauna
It would certainly save a lot of cleanup and for going on cotton pad and wrap
I know you could try it the only thing I would think is if you're putting your castor up
Just on your skin and you're sweating. It's gonna run all over you and be a mess
Um, I don't know give it a try. I would think it's gonna be actually more messy
But yeah, let us know how you do on next week give it a try
Next question. What is the recommended amount of time to have the castor oil pack on
Um usually it's 15 to 30 minutes
So um, that's usually 20 of time
You know, I do know that some people sleep with it on
um
There are castor oil pack
uh
Like uh elastic like rib belt kind of things
That are made to kind of hold a castor oil pack in place and
And um with instructions to sleep with it overnight
I don't know how good an idea that is I would say really 15 to 30 minutes is right because you're trying to draw stuff out
As well, so you don't want that
And drawn out stuff to
To be sitting on your skin that long overnight as well, but so I'd say 15 to 30 minutes
What do you think about tributer and supreme prescribed for me to take help with leaky gut issues? I think
Uh, let's answer that question first
So the tributer and supreme and other buterin pro products are the
Are the main end point fuel stage for um your gut cells
So that's how you heal your gut now you will be making your own buterin if from
um
From uh indegestible fiber so if you're eating a fiber product you're taking sunspectrum or sun fiber or you're eating
Foods with fiber in it
You're making your own buterin to feed your gut cells
Um, but if somebody with a really damaged leaky gut it's always really good to start with a buterin product
So a buterin product is a good thing to to use
Um to help heal the gut. It gives instant fuel to help heal your
Your epithelial cells
Second part of this question also L5MTHFR
Since I think the tributer thinks I need folate according to his muscle tested
I have multiple videos why cancer patients do not want to use methyl groups
So L5MTHFR is a very strong methyl group
And you can be turning off to her suppressor genes by taking that
Besides the fact that you can be pushing your biopterate path you will be pushing your biopterate path very strongly
So I know that a lot of chiropractors are really big into a lot of naturopaths are really big into
taking methyl tetrahedral folate as a product and um
They're ignoring the big picture a couple big pictures even if a person doesn't have a diagnosis of cancer
You have to look genetically in a person's biopterate pathway if they have defects in their comp genes
They're M-A-O-A genes
They're gang genes. You're going to push that pathway quite strongly
and you risk having some mood issues
And and comp issues with breast cancer are a real thing as well. So you're
You're you're that's a risk factor right there
Um, so I'm not a big fan of doing um
of
methyl tetrahedral folate
and the only
The only caveat to that is if a person has elevated homocysteine and you can't get their homocysteine levels down then using some methyl groups to get the homocysteine
groups down
um would be an appropriate call to action
But just because it's coming up under muscle testing, I would be careful of that
And then when you have cancer as a diagnosis and you're going to add methyl groups
You're going to be silency to or suppress your genes
And I'll guarantee you that 99% of chiropractors and dachrats
Do not understand that at all now. I've created multiple videos on that
And you could go on the website and look should cancer patients take methyl groups
Um, they answer that on there
If you could have your carpractor go look at those videos too
So I would say be careful with that
Next question from the chat. I've actually already been doing
It castoral packs um, but just putting the castoral on my liver prior to
My sauna. It's not messy at all
There's slightly oily residue left on the skin
And it didn't even bother to wipe off
It probably comes off when I take a shower afterwards, but nobody
Well, that's good news. That might be a nice time saver for you
And then the next question I've been doing the castoral pack while I do my coffee
Animals is that okay? Yep, that's great thing to do
So you guys are great at killing two birds with one stone, huh
So good
What's your opinion on the keto mojo meter
Which includes the GKI ketones and glucose
I'm not tracking anything currently
Um
I would I would think that that is not
You know, unless you're going to try to go into full keto
Okay, so let's take a step back. So
I
Currently don't have any patients right now that are doing full keto
So there's a big difference between having doing a keto-like diet
And doing a full ketogenic diet
Um, so those who have played with doing a ketogenic diet
actively and used a
uh, keto meter
Realize quite quickly
That it's extremely difficult to truly get into and stay in ketosis
Um, it takes a lot of discipline and um
A lot of self-denial food because it's it's very difficult to get into and stay in a ketogenic state
So by definition a ketogenic state is where you are birding truly birding ketones
And not birding glucose because you almost happened
so um, is it good to get a uh
meter to measure that
Yes, if you're going to do full true ketosis, you're trying to get into full ketosis, you're going to want to measure it
Um, so that you know you're in ketosis. I've had patients with bread cancer that I've tried to get into full ketosis
And maybe we're in ketosis for a day and then their body slips back out of it's very very difficult
so um
There isn't a need for you to do that
Um
Therefore there really isn't a need for you to measure that
Really if you're trying to if you're not dealing with a glioblastoma type brain cancer
um, there really isn't a need to get into ketosis
um
Again, it's very difficult to get into it. It's very difficult to stay in on
And the diet is very difficult to stay on
Even if you can't get into ketosis
When you're doing a more modified ketogenic diet where you're just trying to stay
Keep your glucose levels down
having a more simple
Glucometer with much less expensive
Test reps and a much less expensive glucometer where you could simply buy it at target
And get the test strips who are pretty easy for pretty inexpensively and monitor your glucose
Trying to get your glucose your goal would be if you're in the low 70s would be a perfect goal
We're good as I've been dealing with cancer patients for 30 years now
Then eating zero sugar zero carbs and still can't get their glucose below 90 some people
Sometimes your cell membranes are damaged to the point where you're never going to get into it now
If you're 21 years old
And you want to go on a ketogenic diet for some reason because you're doing some sort of bodybuilding thing or whatever
You're trying to do. It's much easier to get into ketosis. I had a brain cancer patient
um, that got into ketosis
I have
Several glioblastoma patients that got into ketosis and were able to stay in ketosis
On and off for about three months and then finally gave up on the diet and are just out of more modified
ketogenic diet because it's just too difficult to adhere to
And it wasn't they were able to stay in ketosis more than about a week at a time maximum
But they were in their 20s
Very difficult when you're beyond you know 30 years old to do that almost impossible if you're older or less year so
Addicted to fitness that you know that this is your complete lifestyle
So is it important to get a meter like that and to measure ketones? I don't think so
um, you're
The research that's out there for for a cancer patient might as a glioblastoma patient is that would be um
You know, you're gonna have just this lucky benefit as ketosis
By just try to get your glucose levels down and keep them down and stay in a way from as many carbs as possible
Second thing is you don't ever want to go on a you want to be careful let's say the degree of
ketogenic like diet you're on depending upon your current body weight
Some people because you're gonna go on that type of diet. You're gonna lose weight and
And one of the worst things that can take place for a person with a diagnosis of cancer is that they go into what's called
Kexia
Meaning they start dropping pounds that they don't have to lose and when you're losing weight that you don't have
You know you're not you're not overweight
That could be a greater danger than anything else and we've I've counseled people over the years
That were in that state were very obsessed about their diet
And ended up pushing themselves into kexia that they couldn't get out of and it ended up with their demise
So you did to be very careful with that as well
So all those things have to be taken into consideration
Okay, next question is there a recommended
Mid-afternoon stack that would take care of sugar energy drop
Uh
Okay, so that brings up another point
And that you do have to be careful with your diet is that you're not getting
You know, you're everybody's you're staying away from glucose. You're trying to get your blood sugar down
But you do also have to be aware that
You know, maybe you came into this cancer thing maybe not the
Healthiest in the world to begin with and now you're making radical dietary changes
Could you end up with a hypoglycemic state?
Yes, so I think that's part of your question here
That would take care of sugar energy drop if you're dropping into a hypoglycemic state
That can bring danger as well
So
Want to manage your glucose so that you're not dropping into the 50s or 60s which is technically hypoglycemic
That could
cause other issues
um, so
The
Bottom line with um
hypoglycemia is to maintain
Irrable and glucose level by eating some little stacks and things
so um
Fat bone bombs can be good. I think I will recipe on the um
um
Website if I we don't have a recipe for fat bombs
I think they and it actually show they didn't have recipe for fat bombs with coconut oil and peanut butter
um, but if that you could probably find that recipe online as well
It's a common keto keto stack which is really good for your brain
Um, and you could use some honey in it or something like that or maple sugar in it to give a little sweetness to keep your
sugar up as well
Next question finding that I need to go to a conventional
To a convention and concerned about clean food sources
So I may fast
How do you fast when some of the supplements required to be taken with food?
So first of all should a cancer patient fast
Well a cancer patient really shouldn't fast more than 24 hours
Because if you do more than a 24 hour fast
You're going to increase IGF one levels which are growth hormones and you can
Make things worse
So I wouldn't just fast um if you're going to a convention
You can source food in some way by grains and food with you somehow
So you have something to consume
If you're going to be at just a convention for a day is that what you're what I'm understanding then you're not going to eat during that
Day that you're at that convention
Um, yeah, then you could make a smoothie or something to bring with you
That you could take your supplements with your smoothie. Maybe that would be helpful
Um, the only supplement that you really absolutely need to take with food is the
Digestive enzyme with clear digest or HClzyme or digestime plus or whatever you're taking
And if you're not eating then you don't take that so you take that with a meal to help you digest that food
But if you're taking other things with food because you notice that it's helpful
To take it with food then that some
Then you're going to have to come up with something to eat
So you just mentioned that the that it's three days long
There's no way you could have asked for three days
That could be harmful for you
So you're going to have to find some source of food
Do your best that you possibly can i know if you're at a
Convention where there's not a lot of sources around and things
You're just going to you're going to have to do
You know, you just got to make the best choices as all maybe you just get something with a chicken breast or something like that
You just make the best choices you can do
Next question see i seem to need be complex vitamins
What would you suggest when i have is
Pure brand which has folate and lmthfr and b12 with metamorphovolubine
Okay, so if you don't have elevated homocysteine levels
You can't be taking those as a cancer patient
You can do whatever you want, but i'm just telling you in my opinion
You really shouldn't be taking those we have a product on our store
That is b complex dash mf which is methyl free
So it's a b complex
Purposefully made to be methyl free
So i methyl means the methyl comolubine so it's a methyl comolubine
and
folate lmthfr is
methyl tetrahydrofolate so these are going to be
These are going to be donating their methyl groups
So these are methylated vitamins
So again go back on our website
Look at should cancer patients be taking methylated vitamins
Should cancer patients be taking methyl groups
Search for that in the blog and i have multiple videos on that
Um, unless you have elevated homocysteine levels
You should be careful about taking methylated vitamins
methylated vitamins are going to
Turn off to the suppressor genes
So you don't want to do that
Order these and love them
Okay, good. Thank you for that comment
Any other questions
All right. Thank you everybody for being on tonight. It's a good show
And um, we'll see you guys next week. All right. Bye. Bye